we're joined now by CBS News contributor
and author of the Diana Chronicles Tina
Brown is here to you've covered the
royal family extensively so this week so
what do you make of this latest news
this morning that Prince Charles is
gonna walk Megan down the aisle I think
it was a good solution I never really
thought that Dorian would do that you
didn't worry because I think it's a lot
to put on her mother you know she's just
flown in she's the only member of the
family too much too much burden for her
I think is very gallant that Prince
Charles would do that I think it'll look
great the fact that she'll be on his arm
and doesn't it show how much they'd
really embraced her to I think it's very
very gracious of him to do that actually
and particularly after all the kind of
dramas with the family which has been
incredibly painful and they can go Megan
on for Harry I think people are very
very concerned about Megan to make sure
that nothing really spoils her day the
statement that she released yesterday
about her father not attending for
health for health concerns and health
reasons what did you make of that
statement I honestly think that her
father has not been willing or wanting
to handle this I think he's found it all
just too much and I think it's very sad
I think the man is is really overwhelmed
with what's happening to him
unfortunately the Royals have a history
of not being very good at preparing
other people for the massive spotlight
of entering the family and I think that
one of the things that Harry loves about
Megan frankly is that because she's an
actress because she's a star this is not
fazing her you know he got very tired of
all those ex-girlfriends really saying I
can't handle this yes which I understand
from their point of view but from his
point of view is well you may not be
able to handle it but it's my life and
you have to be able to handle it and she
can't and we heard something interesting
too this morning t know that Megan is
going to talk at the reception and that
that is also something that's not done
well it hasn't happened to afford a
royal wedding but I think it's good I
think that Megan is already breaking
with that mold which says that you know
a wife has to be in the background she's
not going to be in the back
she is a woman of independent she's 36
she's a person with a career and she's a
grown-up she's a grownup she's not gonna
just stand there and simple she's gonna
say something and what do you give us
your take on how Diana will be honored
at the service because you've
interviewed Diana you knew Diana what is
your take on that Harry has made it
really clear that he wants to see his
mother as part of this whole thing as he
gets married because there was such an
attempt to shoo her out of the way for
so many years he is really bringing back
the whole memory of Diana that we've
seen that in her engagement ring she had
to deduct diamonds that belong to Diana
she's going to have the white roses that
were Diana's absolute favorite roses
they were all over her memorial chapel
when she died as a memory to her and of
course her sister Lady Jane fellows is
going to be reading which is another way
to include the family so there's a real
sense that diana is with them on what
harry said this crazy journey we're
about to be embarked on and this is this
energy different to you this is my first
royal wedding I haven't covered five but
I am so taken with the energy in this
town and how and the love that people
feel for this couple what do you know
it's interesting about how these royal
weddings bringing them together in this
fantastic way and they always seem to
happen at times when England's been
depressed you know you know when Diana
got married they just come out of the
whole bad that's a time of strikes and
so on and it was a moment of uplift same
thing after the deep recession we had
William Devane
and now after brexit where everyone has
been somewhat bummed out by all the kind
of rancor and a kind of shaky government
now we have this great wedding yeah it's
very happy it feels very very special
thank you Tina Brown I see you tomorrow
of course